parent direct rend le direct merci on
l'a qui voit là l'inspecteur que
tailleur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et sachez que l'amitié reste est souvent
plus longtemps que l'amour et ses amours
platoniques si un plateau
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
merci aux auteurs des gens qui vous
écrit mme les choses mais c'est pas
impressionner je voudrais que tout ce
que tu veux
ne me quitte jamais servi pas du tout
c'est que vous êtes le génie le mozart
du paf ça c'est pas moi qui lis les
audiences en fait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on s'est parlé
[Musique]
c'est la première fois que je vois
aujourd'hui de faire une nouvelle danse
j'aime bien question oui vous un peu
plus légères j'ai passé des questions
juste savoir s'il faisait plutôt un gros
cube city qui m'est personnellement à
mourir oui la gaffe
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais tellement beat bit enfin précisons
le pourtour méditerranéen évidemment la
radio sur l'ailleurs est toujours en
pleine forme
la région la région nord il a fait
plusieurs la région nord c'est plutôt
pluvieux et laisse voilà pour ceux qui
seront ce qu'ils ont un temps qui est
plutôt agréable
il a gardé nos trois températures
d'autres température évidemment leurs
traits à nice 18 à perpignan 14 à
biarritz 15 à sa dette croissante à
pitre on s'arrête 6,14 à paris xii
tourcoing trait à brest voilà et je suis
vous ces observateurs est ce que vous
l'avez vu pourquoi le point rouge
[Rires]
d'amérique la canicule la canicule sur
montcuq du drame
et
[Musique]
3 preuve des trois dernières places
d'une parade américain
moi j'ai vraiment vu que je vais en
faire que disent et c'est surtout pour
aller voir les gens et pour faire
vraiment une énorme d'arcade
voilà c'est tout après voilà michel il
racontait la télé et arthur voilà faut
pas prendre ça à la légère ce que j'ai
eu écho qui avait une réunion de crise
hier avec des producteurs de spectacles
parisiens ils ont peur que vous si
fonnier tous les téléspectateurs et que
du coup sa visite
je donnerai des nouvelles les chéris